when you put in when you type that it
should come to you and say do you want
to add sliders do you see that it gives
you some buttons there are you up to
date yet not up to there yet that's okay
when you get there that's why I have
these are one two three sliders down
here that allow me to vary the values of
a B and C okay so I've got my
coefficients there you can see this is
the familiar come quadratic I've been
given you over and over again right this
is x squared plus 5x plus 6 right are
you sick of this quadratic yeah okay now
there are two roots negative no you're
three just as you expected okay now
here's what's really interesting I've
got I've got these three guys and the
reason I put them on sliders is
precisely so I can muck around with them
okay now we're going to muck around with
them in a specific order all happen when
we change see now you know what C is
from the general form what does see tell
us about the quadratic tell us the
y-intercept so if i change this value up
and down it should change this value up
and down do you agree so it should slide
up and down that's no big deal let's see
what happens see there we go so down oh
sure that's exactly what you expected
that's no surprises there okay ah now
he's a really important moment take it
for what it's worth a and B I am also
going to modify but they are not nearly
as obvious what do you expect will
happen to be first as I change be up and
then you ever think about it for a
second make a dip prediction maybe drive
it down right what would you expect is
going to happen to the shape of it the
position of it
you've had a second to think who'd like
to adventure for it and by the way total
guesses unless you've done this before
right right now I think you had your
hand up first tell us just one thing
that you expect okay we're thinking
there might be some horizontal movement
okay I think there will be some
horizontal movement part of the reason
why is because when we factorize right
when we factorize the value of this
number changes what your factorization
will be it changes these numbers right
and when you chase these numbers you go
that's the right so I think that's good
but I think there's going to be more
there any other suggestions for changes
some of the roots will change well
there's only this to like if you change
one of the roots because it the B is
involved in our book must be not exactly
right very good changes okay good all
right let me should write this back down
right because it's crucial this is the
way I'm showing me this okay you're
exactly right that once you change one
of the roots you're necessarily a
changing your okay because these two are
or there's the be that I'm changing
right so you expect debling together let
me ask you this question I'll Fraser
different way I asked you what would
change okay so we said some horizontal
movement roots what's going to stay the
same is there anything that's gonna stay
the same ah good so you notice if I muck
around with this I go up and down but if
I lock it in position it's 5.1 at the
moment it should stay put that point
should say what shouldn't go anywhere
right is there anything else that you
would expect that would stay the same
still be a problem I shall show you
right yeah right I steep this subject
code would stay the same salumeria so so
when you compare like this guy with this
guy right let you convince them the
picture that okay i'm just getting
steeper thinner if you like right but
i'm not changing that number and leaving
it at one so i'm going to expect see how
steep it is at the moment i'm gonna sort
of expected that and stay put okay all
right ready no change oh one more round
okay all right let's give this a go to
shall we and we'll see what happens to
concur v and then what you pretty did
what was going to change what was going
to stay the same zoom out just a little
bit okay here we get pretty
what I'm just getting his play because
I'm lazy okay what's going on it's going
back and forth what did you tell me
would stay the same one you're talking
about why do second stay the same bingo
right there okay you also told me that
its steepness and stay the same so it's
just kind of shifting back and forth and
moving around I'll show you where it's
moving around it's moving around i think
it's this one there we go the vertex of
the parabola is moving on a parabola can
you see it slide wait which problem oh
it's there it's on the my fellows books
now i will let you have a thing as to
why you'll notice there's a conspicuous
absence from this it would be all rather
there's a value of B that is 0 right why
would that be and it is just that you
have to think about it okay I'm just
more interested in raising questions
right now okay last little bit here
let's let's stop spitting it out okay
source to get back okay now you might be
a little more informed that'll be about
what will happen if I change a you're
already expecting something are you
expecting something so speak this will
change good okay what's going to stay
the same
not necessarily let me ask you this
question let me asking this question um
hits a concave up a happy prattler right
because a is positive right now okay
what do you expect will happen as a
changes well I think you can imagine
what happens is it gets debug what
happens is it's going to change this way
because at some point at some point it's
going to have to turn into concave down
isn't it it's gonna have to turn from
that ah because when is it going it's
going to flatten out when's it gonna
flatten when a is equal to 0 because we
just get this library okay you ready
let's hit play it's a lie okay now
what's it doing it's getting steeper
it's getting steeper but then it's going
to come back watch it watch it carefully
whoa did you catch it let me slow it
down slow it down for you okay no wait I
want to do okay so you can see I've
slowed it down a bit a third speed
almost so we get steeper and steeper and
steeper through the y intercept is the
same it's still the same okay but now
it's coming back down as it approaches
zero watch what happens here comes down
now it flattens out because I has to
turn concave down right now what's it
moving remember i showed you that
parabola before that was sliding around
and around okay well here it is this is
there let me who my country's a call on
them I'm just going to leave your bed
there we go now what's happening he up
speed back up
p so why does it like gar really quickly
do your house he goes Florence it's a
great that's a great question I want you
to think about that there is it seems to
just let not go anywhere for ages and
adhere just like we very dramatic change
why there's a real answer that question
there's a real numerical answer that
question okay now let me pause because
because while you're watching the
animation you're like I'm listening to
nothing but you're saying right now okay
so let me bring back down okay there we
go now here comes my real big question
why I shows you all of this okay um I'm
going to take away these okay one of the
great things if you haven't discovered
it that des mas already is that it'll
just to doesn't just do graphs it also
does calculations so I can get a clean
these guys right so I can put in minus B
a and it spits out of the buck okay let
me just go back to my favorite parabola
x squared plus 5x plus 6
okay big right the sum of the roots it's
negative 5 that makes sense doesn't it
oh you got there to negative 3 you Adam
no big deal okay I can also calculate a
product of ribbon here see on a so it's
six because negative 2 times negative 3
equals positive 6 no problem right okay
now watch what happens when I do this
I'm going to move it up i'm going to use
seeded i'm just going to slide it
straight up okay i just go and tell you
a little bit now tell me where are the
roots they don't exist on this graph do
that you're absolutely right and yet
according to this my roots hip don't
exist they still add up to negative 5
and apparently now they multiply 27.6
these routes that well from this guy a
squared minus 4ac it's negative was that
mean that's the discriminant no real
roots no real roots but there are two on
real ribs whatever they they are
wherever they are and you can still add
them and you can still multiply them and
you get these numbers ok now we're going
to dig further into this convinced you
yet that despite it being a simple thing
you can think deeply about it and the
rabbit hole goes way way down okay this
is a bit of a teaser but it begs the
question now like I know how to
calculate these but what do they even
mean